bonjour mesdames bonjour messieurs
sur la proposition de la première
ministre
chargé de la planification écologique et
énergétique
le président de la république a nommé
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur
madame catherine colonna
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères
monsieur eric dupond-moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame amélie de montchalin
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur pape ndiaye
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
monsieur sébastien lecornu
ministre des armées
madame brigitte bourguignon
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur olivier du soft
ministre du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
monsieur damien abad
ministre des solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées
madame sylvie retailleau
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
monsieur marc fesneau
ministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
monsieur stanislas guérini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique
manas michael brown pie v
ministre d outre-mer
madame rima abdel malak
ministre de la culture
madame agnès pannier une hache et
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame amélie oudéa castéra
ministre des sports et des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
sont nommés ministres délégués
auprès de la première ministre
monsieur olivier véran
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et de la vie démocratique
madame isabelle rom
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes de la diversité et de
l'égalité des chances
auprès du ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
monsieur gabriel attal chargé des
comptes publics
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur et de
la ministre de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur christophe béchu chargé des
collectivités territoriales
auprès de la ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur franck
riester
chargé du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité
monsieur clément bonne chargé de
l'europe
sont nommé secrétaire d'état
auprès de la première ministre
madame olivia grégoire
porte-parole du gouvernement
madame justine bénin
chargé de la mer
madame charlotte caubel
chargée de l'enfance
auprès de la ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères madame crise ou là à
carreaux poulou chargé du développement
de la francophonie et des partenariats
internationaux
le président de la république réunira le
conseil des ministres avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement
lundi 23 mai à 10 heures
[Musique]